for the eagle
look how proud that is oh come through
minnie me tiger woods and his 11 year
old son charlie were the talk of the
sports world when they played together a
couple weeks ago and by the way
that was charlie's very first evening oh
and it was so much fun to watch
meanwhile tiger himself is making
headlines again indeed he is a new
documentary is looking back on tiger's
meteoric rise and fall
one that eventually led to the ultimate
comeback
i am deeply sorry for my irresponsible
and selfish behavior why
did you want to take on the topic of
tiger woods on thanksgiving night in
2009
we realized that we know next to nothing
about him and
i think that raised a very interesting
question which is who is tiger woods
you know we all knew that tiger started
playing golf so early i didn't realize
it was actually when he was eight months
old pion strapped him out of his high
chair one day and he walked over
and hit the ball and i guess i always
knew that that earl was a bit of a
helicopter parent
um but i didn't realize like how he had
such a vision i think earl's
outsized impact on tiger was huge
tiger's troubles began in 2009 when he
crashed his suv
into a tree justice's marriage to wife
elon nordegren was unraveling amid
reports of marital infidelity
enter rachel yucatel tiger's former
mistress who sat down with filmmakers
for the hbo dock which debuts on sunday
here he was in my bed and he was
my tiger this wasn't just
sexual affairs this was tiger trying to
find intimacy
tiger had a stunning comeback in 2019
another bright spot his 11 year old mini
me son
the mannerisms club twirls the gate the
fist pumps
like father like son that's them in sync
on the course
last month charlie who has his dad's
competitive spirit
is tiger's second child with elin you're
starting a family you want to have a big
family one day
yeah we definitely i don't want a big
family but i certainly want to have have
more in the future
i think you know the big question is
what lessons has he learned now
as a parent with young kids is he the
same father that his father was or has
he learned
i think that's the question